casas completamente destruidas en
solamente cuatro minutos dos días
después del paso de los tornados en
kentucky los supervivientes se esfuerzan
por darse cuenta de lo que les ha
ocurrido
después de que oímos que todo se detuvo
saque mi cabeza y me iré con mi linterna
hacia el borde de la casa y me di cuenta
de que no había ninguna pared allí y ahí
fue cuando le dije a mi esposa le dije
quiero advertirte ahora mismo cuando
subamos ahí no creo que la casa esté ahí
y efectivamente ese extremo de la casa
ya no estaba cuando finalmente salimos a
la mañana siguiente
algunos parientes de esta familia
vinieron a ayudarles a buscar lo que
pueden salvar después del desastre
esto horrible es la definición del
infierno en la tierra yo puedo la gente
lo ha perdido todo es terrible es
horrible
aquí en el sur oeste de kentucky como en
otros ocho estados del país los
escombros se extienden hasta donde
alcanza la vista se cree que más de 100
personas fallecieron pero este recuento
podría aumentar